et dans l'ensemble sur l'ensemble du
territoire nationale hexagonale
exclusivement d'ailleurs il faudra quand
même une porte de sortie de deux choses
l'une soit on arrive sur une espèce
c'est ce que nous nous avons demandé au
parti socialiste et au groupe socialiste
c'est de faire une grande conférence
sociale soit il fait une grande
consultation une grande loi mais il
faudra quand même qu' il y ait du
concret après ces mois de rencontres
vous avez signalé que deux mesures entre
environ une journée
et si vous avez donc signalé que savait
que c'était encore savait pas été fait
mais on s'est expliqué je me suis trompé
de mots en gros je me suis mal exprimé
c'est courant 2009 moi je je veux bien
qu'on comprenne super dans la polémique
moi je suis député les députés ont deux
fonctions faire la loi et contrôler
l'action du gouvernement dans ce cadre
là on fait entre autres des questions
gouvernement c'est ce que j'ai fait la
semaine dernière au vu de ce que les
journalistes locaux avaient écrit en
disant qu'ils s'étaient renseignés qu'il
n'y avait pas de nouvelles et donc je
fais une question au gouvernement à la
ministre en charge qui est madame busin
puisque c'est elle qui nous unissent de
la santé et la réponse a été ben
clairement ça va pas être au 1er janvier
moi ce que je remarque j'ai eu à gérer
des crises quand même et en particulier
celle de la guyane et les auditeurs
comprennent lorsque chacun d'entre nous
vous
quiconque a à intervenir vous relisez ce
que vous avez à dire alors imaginez
ministre en situation de crise lorsque
j'étais en guyane avant chaque prise de
parole je relisais ce qu'on me propose
et je modifiais je peux aimer mans c'est
très important parce que il s'agit de la
responsabilité de la crédibilité de la
parole politique
et justement cette crise des gilet jaune
ici comme ailleurs
questionne la crédibilité de la parole
politique et c'est dans ce sens là que
j'ai posé la question et jus
la réponse voilà donc sa réponse ne me
satisfait pas parce que c'est pas une
réponse acceptable pas se tromper sur un
sujet aussi dans l'urgence de la
situation qui était voilà qui on imagine
que les discours sont écrits à pinon et
sont peut-être un peu improvisé amoureux
elle est plus simplement se tromper
non vraiment je veux pas qu'on fasse une
polémique là-dessus parce que c'est pas
le but mais honnêtement non pourquoi
parce que lorsqu'on propose des mesures
de sortie de crise les mesures de sortie
de crise elle son riz mais elles sont
validées elles rient mais c'est le le
jargon ça veut dire qu'elles ont été
autorisés par les ministres qui gère le
dossier on passe en interministériel et
donc comme la dépense ne dépend pas du
ministère d outre-mer dont pas du
portefeuille financier de la mise d
outre-mer mais deux madame buza il
aurait été normal c'est ce que j'ai fait
en guyane lorsque s'adapte aux dépens
d'un autre ministre que moi d'appeler le
ministre pour dire écoute je vais faire
cette annonce
est ce que toi ça te va est ce que tu as
l'argent etc c'est comme ça qu'on fait
et ça ça sécurise la décision vendredi
des élus ultra marins étaient en vie
l'elysée a participé à une rencontre une
grande rencontre avec le président on va
parler du fond soit franc vous êtes venu
vous il ya presque reparti pour
l'expliquer je le confort de ses news
on s'en fout ce n'était pas utile jamais
pensé qu'une rencontre entre les maires
et le président la république ça puisse
alors qu'elle joue si bien sûr que j'ai
pu espérer que ça serve à quelque chose
parce que on
froidement on ne peut pas imaginer qu'on
dise à des maires de laisser leur
commune de faire des dépenses parce
qu'il ya des dépenses il ya un voyage il
ya un séjour qui est payé par éléphant
public s'est payée par les communes je
crois a priori c'est par les communes
donc il ya une dépense derrière il ya de
l'espérance aussi derrière sans imaginer
que cet exercice allait être utile j'ai
assisté les deux premières heures donc
j'ai entendu les interventions des uns
et des autres j'ai vu l'organisation
j'ai vu que ils attendaient 200 élus et
au final on était une petite petite
soixantaine y compris des parlementaires
qui étaient là mais qu'ils n'avaient pas
droit à la parole donc au final c'était
une 50 40 personnes qui allaient parler
je me suis dit on n'est pas dans le
format on n'est absolument pas dans le
format en plus il n'y a eu aucune
coordination
je veux dire même si les parlementaires
n'avaient pas intervenir mais on aurait
pu au moins nous inviter à des réunions
de concertation pour échanger sur ce qui
allait être disent qu'on allait pouvoir
demander au président d'un point de vue
un peu global
on aurait pu échanger sur le projet
aussi parce que bien sûr ce sont des
demandes assez circonscrite en mairie on
a entendu aux antilles et à la réunion
et mayotte
mais on aurait pu parler projet global
des territoires et ça ça n'a pas été le
cas donc ça a été au final un échange
mais plutôt une opération de
communication
est ce que les élus les maires ou les
porte parole des jeunes cadres de ce qui
s'est exprimé en 7 et social bien sûr
[Musique]
les jeux ne veulent plus que vous soyez
là c'est notre fonction nous avons été
élus pour ça c'est ce que nous faisons
en tout cas moi en tant que député c'est
ce que je fais depuis 2012 on a vous
m'avez invité plusieurs fois sur
beaucoup de sujets la vie chère la loi
transition énergétique tous ces sujets
d'ailleurs qui reviennent ou j'entends
des propositions qu'on avait formulées
ici même
et porter dans la loi donc valider des
choses qu'on a avancé et c'est donc
c'est notre fonction de le faire de
porter la parole des gilet jaune mais au
delà des jets d'oeufs les jeunes de la
population de toute la population de des
territoires sur lesquels on induit des
circonscriptions de la réunion mais
aussi de la nation puisqu'on est député
de la nation tout entière donc on est
aujourd'hui dans un système
représentatif donc les gens élisent des
représentants et ses représentants
aujourd'hui sont légitimes pour le faire
mais encore une fois sur le travail des
élus on ne peut pas faire un travail
isolé un élu il doit être au contact de
la population y portent le message et la
voix de son territoire lorsque je porte
la voix sur les centres d'intérêt moreau
et le retour des réunionnais ici ou dans
les autres dom
j'ai pas inventé c'est que pendant deux
ans j'ai travaillé avec les associations
porter le crefor etc qui ont porté ce
message et on a travaillé ensemble donc
il faut travailler avec les gens il faut
porter la voix et se battre pour les
messages et les problèmes de nos
territoires sur lesquels on est élu
est-ce que c'est finalement les partis
politiques en tant que tels qu'ils sont
c'est difficile aujourd'hui d'être élu
sur une ligne politique sur un parti
alors que visiblement l'idée de droite
et nous sommes brouillés que
vous même vous avez fait campagne lors
des dernières sessions sans faire
référence au parti socialiste vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition c'est très
compliqué pour les acteurs peut-être de
confiance au départ sur les cinq ans qui
viennent sur une ligne qui peut être
changeantes qui est partisane elle j'en
prends plus passer mon deuxième mandat
donc c'était une confiance renouvelée
quand même donc et la confiance qui m'a
été donnée en 2017 avec le un taux
d'abstention important quand même hein
il faut que chaque élu est bien ça en
tête on y est lui mais on a un fort taux
d'abstention donc ce phénomène là de
délitement de la démocratie date pas
d'aujourd'hui ça fait très très très
longtemps mais ça a été renouvelée d'une
part sur le travail effectué qui était
reconnue sur la proximité sur la
présence sur cette abstention importante
et 7d bien sûr mais c'est ce que je
disais c'est que je l'entends pas
aujourd'hui je l'entends hier puisque je
j'ai conscience que j'ai été élu en 2017
mais aussi en 2012 et d'autres avant moi
ont été élus avec un délitement de la
mobilisation des gens donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait par rapport à ça on essaie de
faire au mieux c'est à dire être sur le
terrain dans la proximité travailler
avec les gens c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure et être à l'écouté
constructif en même temps les gens
votent pour des personnalités pour un
bilan est aussi pour
une vision du de politique du territoire
qu'est ce qu'on a comme vision quelle
est notre projet pour le territoire
j'ai toujours porté cette idée de
ancrage océanique jette aujourd'hui la
france allait pas hexagonal et
océaniques j'ai toujours porté le fait
qu'on devait proposer un aller et un
retour un développement économique qui
produisent de la richesse je regardais
dans la presse aujourd'hui
bon on est en 2019 avec -15% en
exportations et des importations qui
augmente ça veut dire qu'on n'a même pas
aujourd'hui un projet régional
économique qui permet de créer de la
richesse
aujourd'hui on continue à envoyer ses
sur l'action je vous pose est est-ce
qu'on peut encore aujourd'hui faire la
politique partisane
est ce que c'est ce que j'ai fait ce que
l'on peut dire qu'elle est deux
je pense qu'elles les deux je pense
qu'il ya une partie il ya une partie
partisane et une partie bien sûr liée à
la confiance qu'on peut donner à telle
ou telle personne c'est les gens qui me
disent sur le terrain mais ce n'est pas
gagné qu'avec des gens de gauche
j'ai aussi gagné avec des gens qui très
certainement ne sont pas militants au
parti socialiste parce que il adhère sur
le projet que je porte et la façon dont
j'apporte j'aborde le sujet moi je suis
dans une approche non partisane dans ma
relation avec les gens pour revenir à
des choses plus concrètes sur ce qui
s'est dit notamment
vendredi 18 l'outre-mer se contente que
le présent décret qui la question la
surrémunération des fonctionnaires
est-ce que c'est pertinent pour
s'attaquer à limiter aux primes de vie
chère
est ce que le sujet on y voit tout cas
on lui a fait un cadeau on pose en la
remettant la question sur jeu
avez vous lu a fait un cadeau en mettant
le sujet sur la table parce que seul je
pense qu'il serait pas venu sur sur sur
ce sujet moi je suis contre et je
l'étais pas hier je l'étais quand
j'étais ministre parce que je vous
rappelle que pour la loi égalité réelle
certains auraient souhaité que j'abhorre
de cette question dans la loi égalité
réelle et ça a été niet et j'ai expliqué
et au président de la république et au
premier ministre que si c'était le cas
c'était sans moi donc on l'a pas fait et
je suis contre sur le même motif qu'ils
ont fondé mon opposition à la réforme
proposée par la ministre d outre-mer et
voter sur la réforme de l'abattement des
30 % de l'impôt sur le revenu pourquoi
parce que d'abord si on s'attaque à
cette surrémunération on s'attaque pas
aux plus riches
on s'attaque à la classe moyenne parce
que c'est pas des gens qui touchent dsf
qui sont visés et dans le même temps au
niveau national le président de la
république et son gouvernement n'hésite
pas à faire un cadeau de 5 milliards sur
l' isf puisque aujourd'hui ces gens ne
payent pas donc pourquoi je ne suis pas
entré de l'inégalité et en quoi ça ne
créerait pas de l'inégalité en
supprimant puisque cet argent c'est
juste un moyen de faire des économies
cet argent resterait au niveau national
dans les caisses du départ de deux du
gouvernement ne reviendrait pas sur le
territoire enfin on connaît la petite
pratique un regarder sur le rsa le rsa
raffarin disait ce sera compensée à
l'euro près en 2019 s'est toujours pas
compensé à l'euro près donc on connaît
la musique
on a l'expérience et d'autre part la
maison de monter au créneau il a raison
et j'ai je pense qu'il va être entendu
en tout cas je l'espère et d'autre part
ça va appauvrir si ça appauvrit ça veut
dire que on impacte l'économie de la
réunion ce qui aujourd'hui consomme ce
qui aujourd'hui construit une maison
achète un appartement achète une voiture
ils feront pas et on restera toujours
avec les 40 % les plus pauvres en ayant
un peu plus de gens qui n'ont pas de
capacité d'investir donc tout le btp ça
va prendre un coup toutes les
entreprises qui offrent du service ça va
prendre un coup
tout ça ça va appauvrir le territoire
au lieu de d'être dans une dynamique et
cognitive je crois se détendre et d
assurer les autres non c'était privé et
peut-être même qu'elle favorise ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui c'est un vrai projet de
développement économique au niveau
national mais au niveau régional on a un
temps qui va s'ouvrir dans quelques
semaines quelques mois c'est la forclaz
la signature des plans de convergence
vous savez c'est qu'on craque on va
compte signer avec était dans la loi
égalité réelle que le gouvernement
accepte enfin de mettre en oeuvre ça a
été signé pour mayotte et la guadeloupe
et ça va être signée pour pour la
réunion ça veut dire qu'elle est d' état
région europe on met sur la table pour
créer de l'activité économique et donc
de l'emploi avec des vrais salaires pas
des salaires comme la réforme des aides
économiques que nous a proposé la
ministre d outre mer qui fait
aujourd'hui on est sur des trappes à bas
salaire toutes les aides d'exonérations
de cotisations patronales sur les plus
bas salaires ça veut dire que au final
on stimule pas l'entreprise pour qu'elle
fasse des vraies politiques salariales
et rémunère bien dans le privé
tant qu'on est là dessus on ne sera pas
sur une réduction de l'écart entre les
plus riches et les plus pauvres
à propos de lui contre je suis très
content parce qu'il ya une loi pour ça
c'est la loi lurel qui a été voté en
et moi je le plains pourquoi pas oui il
ya des choses qui ont beaucoup avancé et
moi j'ai entendu fouassin qui dit on va
voter une loi non mais la loi elles
existent donc ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a fait le
roaming
1 on est revenu sur le roaming le
téléphone on a remis de la concurrence
dans ce domaine là on a fait des sur les
tarifs bancaires
on a mis le bécut et on a mis des
amendes à ceux qui étaient présents pour
bien sûr la grande distribution
on a mis des amendes sur ce qui était en
position dominante
j'ai fait un courrier au premier
ministre datant du 18 janvier
signé par beaucoup de députés par le
conseil départemental et les chambres
consulaires
tout le monde n'a pas signé je le
regrette pour demander qu'on régule les
prix sur les matériaux de construction
je vous laisserai ceux qui n'ont pas
signé il ya la région qui n'a pas signé
et la chambre dans la chambre de
commerce la chambre de commerce n'a pas
su me semble-t-il voilà mais sinon les
tout le monde a signé et je le regrette
parce que ça c'est une situation de
monopole sur les matériaux de
construction et les matériaux de
construction
quand vous avez année par un écart de 40
% ça fait que quand vous achetez votre
maison vous construisez votre maison ça
fait ça fait cher sur l'alimentation
l'automobile sur les brevets sur les
pièces détachées
je suis allé voir mon et la semaine
dernière la présidente de l'autorité de
la concurrence où je lui ai dit les
pièces détachées je lui ai dit les
matériaux de construction et je lui ai
dit sur les produits alimentaires
écoutez sur les produits alimentaires
alors moi je suis très heureuse de voir
que tous ces sujets sur lesquels on
travaille depuis 2012 ou autour de la
table j'ai vu personne n'a loupé mais
toutes ces collectivités qui doivent
siéger ne viennent jamais et là tous
high roller des prix le marché des
revenus donc c'est très très bien et je
lui ai dit à elle à l'autorité de la
concurrence
il faut que nous fassions comme sur les
carburants et carburant c'est quand même
nous maîtriser les marges
il faut que nous sachions cantat paquets
de biscuits une plaquette de beurre
quitte l'hexagone et arrive dans un
supermarché ici qui s'enrichit sur toute
la chaîne depuis l' usine jusqu'au
supermarché on l'a fait sur total non on
le sait pas parce qu'on est non on le
sait pas on n'a pas fait étape par étape
le camion combien il prend au port à
marseille combien y prend et c est ça
sur france 2
de l'autre nom de l'autorité de la
concurrence qui fait cette démarche
cette étude en ce moment je lui ai
demandé de le faire pourquoi parce que
lors du débat à paris la proposition
pour laquelle je n'ai je n'étais pas
d'accord qui consiste à dire on va
prendre l'impôt des réunionnais pour
subventionner le fret
alors qu'on ne sait même pas s'il y a
des marges inacceptable sur le fret
c'est ça c'est niet
et d'ailleurs le président de la
république il a dit non c'est un vrai
sujet
si on vient avec des propositions gérard
parce que la réglementation européenne
va considérer ça comme une aide directe
et les aides directes aux entreprises
c'est à l'encontre des principes
concurrentielles européennes et je ne
vois pas pourquoi un citoyen européen va
subventionner c est ma cg m enfin pour
ne citer qu'eux mais d'autres compagnies
sans savoir quelle est la marge et
combien ça coûte c'est inacceptable donc
on vient avec des propositions qui ne
sont pas crédibles devant le président
de la république ça pose un problème de
crédibilité de notre présentation quand
on est à paris quand même on entend ce
que vous dites sur les choses qui sont d
autres jusqu en char qui dit les
placards du ministère sont plaints des
moustiques plein qu'est ce qu'on attend
pour bien en place et cd musique et on
peut vous retourner la question vous qui
avez été des couleurs des années et
chaque nouveau ministre
[Musique]
mais on l'a on a des outils aussi
maintenant et les outils faut les
appliquer quand on a une loi égalité
réelle sur lesquels on a du rattrapage
sociale mais aussi
des directives pour appliquer des choses
pour lutter contre les situations
inacceptables qui impacte le prix le
pouvoir d'achat qu'est-ce qu'on
attaquait ce que ce gouvernement attend
pour mettre en place la loi égalité
réelle qui a été voté à l'unanimité par
toutes tendances confondues à
l'assemblée et au sénat
qu'est ce qu'on attend qu'est-ce qu'on
attend sur les services de l'état de la
route moi je sais pas ce qu'ils
attendent parce que encore une fois les
outils existent il faut alors moi j'ai
apprécié quand même ce que dit le
président de la république quand il dit
bon chiche on y va chiche
on y va il supposé il disait grosso modo
ça va faire bouger les choses et ça va
faire du bruit sur les territoires mais
faisons lorsque oui alors lorsque plus
précisément sur cette question il dit
les politiques sont ralliés finalement
ces entreprises qui sont en situation de
monopole par endroit voire même se
financer directement
est-ce que le cd réunion dans l'après
midi
est ce que ça peut gêner effectivement
ça peut peut-être gêné mais là n'est pas
la question la loi que j'ai portée et la
loi pour laquelle j'étais rapporteur
dans ces deux lois c'est clair il ya des
outils pour lutter contre les situations
de monopole
nous on a et en tant que ministre par
exemple sur les matériaux de
construction c'est moi qui ai 6 et saisi
michel sapin donc on a eu ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc on a avancé là dessus
mais lorsqu'on a fait la loi
lurel et que j'étais rapporteur
effectivement quand j'ai rencontré que
ce soit totale monsieur de margerie qui
est décédé lorsque j'ai rencontré dans
le numérique
les uns et les autres lorsque j'ai
rencontré les industriels locaux etc
je sentais bien qu'il y avait de la
résistance mais et alors nous notre
boulot c'est pas de se plier à la
résistance c'est d'y aller
d'autant que si on le fait c'est pas
pour tuer la production locale la preuve
c'est que la production locale
elle a pris sa part est de plus en plus
moi je suis pour le développement des
filières ses volailles avec art et essai
produite dégagement qui arrivent sur le
territoire donc d'une part on doit
développer les filières faire une
production locale adaptée aux
portefeuilles des réunionnais et il faut
développer cela et ne pas se laisser
marcher sur les pieds par des
entreprises qui ont des situation
d'oligopole et de monopole qui ne
contribue pas à l'intérêt général c'est
ça qu'il faut faire cesser ces
entreprises je me rappelle de margerie
m'avait dit nous suivent vous continuez
à nous embêter on quitte les outre-mers
ben on lui a dit j'étais avec mon
collègue de mayotte ibrahim aboubacar on
lui a dit a quitté les outre-mer
monsieur pour lui n'a pas quitté un les
outre-mer d'un point de vue
institutionnel et de questionnements
autour de la démocratie telle que de
l'émission de sensualité de
différenciation est ce que ça signifie
la différenciation oui parce que c'est
ces mots là kik
oui qui sont travestis la
différenciation c'est les contrats de
convergence dans la loi égalité réelle
ça veut dire que mais c'est du buzz à
bas ça veut dire que mayotte paris tours
mais oui mais je n'ai pas la fourrure la
réunion c'est pas les antilles etc etc
bon bah ça on le sait est donc on fait
des contrats différenciée selon les
territoires pour le développement ça
existe mais tout ça pour quoi
pour ne pas parler de la suppression
d'un amendement virapoullé cette
élection ça qu'il faut aller plus loin
en fait diversion pour ne pas supprimer
l'amendement virapoullé nous en demande
et pourquoi ne voudrait-il pas le
supprimer parce que nous dit-il ça c'est
la ministre de la justice a qu'on a
interrogés qui nous l'a dit c'est le
cabinet la conseillère du président pas
plus tard que vendredi
qui dit on n'est pas tous d'accord mais
j'ai dit si on est tous d'accord
regardez la population la demande et les
gels et jableh ben voilà il y en a qui
d'hommes qui disent qu'ils sont pas
d'accord et donc du coup le gouvernement
dit en tout le monde ne demande pas eh
ben on ne fait pas voilà la réalité des
choses ça c'est la réalité de ce sont
les faits or nous on a déjà proposé une
ppl mois depuis une proposition mois
depuis 2013 mais on n'a pas eu le la
réunion du congrès donc on n'a pas pu le
faire et là jean hugues ratenon a fait
un rapport avec un député la république
en marche nous avons collectivement
certains députés david lorient huguette
bello
jean hugues ratenon et moi même en tant
que député nous avons travaillé pour
faire une proposition collective
bon il se trouve qu'il ya eu la sphère
bennama benalla et donc ça a été
suspendu on n'avait pas la bénédiction
du gouvernement à on nous a dit retirer
votre amendement on verra comment on
travaille c'est une erreur fondamentale
au lieu de parler possibilité d'aller
plus loin pour expérimenter des choses
qui sont véritablement possible sur le
sur la réunion on nous parle de
différenciation d'ailleurs madame
penchard est allés dans notre sens
puisqu'elle a dit vous voyez à quel
point il est difficile d'avoir de
l'exception quand on vient à paris à
l'assemblée nationale laissez-nous faire
les choses localement
toujours à propos de démocratie est ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut dans ces
régions qui l'ont référendum
d'initiative citoyenne est ce que le
conseil consultatif puisqu'ils sont
intéressantes
justement
un peu plus oui moi je trouve que la
participation citoyenne
encore une fois et devra continuer à
être un mode de fonctionnement
on ne peut pas faire les choses sans les
citoyens c'est du terrain enfin moi je
le fais dans ma circonscription c'est du
terrain c'est de l'écouter c'est de la
compréhension réelle des sujets on ne
peut pas être hors sol et se dire j'ai
une idée tient son nom mais votre idée
elle peut être pas bonne il faut aller
là confronté avec ce que veulent les
gens et il faut comprendre quel sens
cela sur le territoire oui les citoyens
participant à la vie politique
ces signes d'une grande maturité d'une
d'une république
et ça ça manque beaucoup ça a manqué et
ça manque beaucoup à la france est ce
que concrètement est ce que l'idée d'un
conseil consultatif citoyen qui permet
aux citoyens éventuellement de faire
avancer des idées de les proposer
avec toujours ces représentations ce que
c'est plutôt ça qui vous intéresse ou le
référendum moi je préfère la première
formule parce que je pense que je prends
en économie mais je prends aussi en
social on a besoin de stabilité des
droits par exemple à mon social ou même
en économie et donc lorsqu'on s'est
décidé sur quelque chose il ne s'agirait
pas que en fonction des desiderata d'une
population qui varient aussi qu'on
remette continuellement des choses qui
ont été arrêtés parce qu'autrement
quelqu'un qui a un droit social
aujourd'hui pourrait le perdre demain il
y aurait une vraie instabilité qui
serait même contre-productive pour la
population ce ne serait pas bon donc il
faut une certaine stabilité je pense
qu'on peut aller un peu plus loin
moi je réfléchis là dessus sur le
consultatif dans le monde il ya des
expériences dans en france aussi des
villes des régions qui vont assez loin
mais je ferai des propositions temps et
en heure sur cette participation qui
peut être aussi concrètes sur des
projets avec des vrais leviers
décisionnel dans quelques instants après
des questions de deux auditeurs des
habitants avant ça juste quelques jours
de politique
les prochaines échéances européennes
ensuite législatives d'avoir les
initiales puis les régionales question
que j'ai posée la semaine dernière on
vous verra ou ak moudre toutes ses
chances ben tout le temps à tous non non
non je serai active sur les trois
sélections sur les européennes sur les
municipales et sur les régionales
donc je serai sur le terrain je
défendrai ma question est la candidate
quelques pistes européennes
non non non pas les organes est ce qu'on
peut vous voir
oui deux non non non non non je crois
pas non vous croyez pas où vous savez
pas non non non non je pour l'instant je
suis sûr j'espère qu'on me proposera
d'être sur la liste aux municipales moi
je suis conseillère municipale je suis
contre le cumul des fonctions donc je le
fais depuis 2012
ça me va très bien je donne du temps la
ville j'aime faire ce que j'ai je fais
donc j'aimerais bien continuer sur veux
bien que je sois sur la liste pour les
régionales
2021 quoi on % pour imaginer qu'à
mariage candidat tête de liste pour les
jeunes je sais pas dans le contexte
c'est compliqué à vous dire ça
on est sur un mandat et puis après
franchement je veux pas faire la langue
de bois mais c'est comme si on se
projeter en disant je suis déjà sur
autre chose au final je m'en fiche un
peu de mon mandat
cc c'est pas bien on va revoir où on a
des questions d'auditeurs à commencer
par gilberte qui est par téléphone pour
poser une question à eric à la
découverte
bonjour là bonjour en fait tous ceux qui
sont sur le plateau il ya une chose que
je n'ai pas compris hein j'ai bien vu
que les sénateurs étaient présents à la
réunion monsieur macro mais ils n'ont
pas eu l'occasion de parler et les
maires qui ont présenté les doléances
qu'ils avaient ils l'ont fait rythme est
ce que moi je n'ai pas compris c'est que
le mouvement des jeunes ils ont été
lancé à l'appel de monsieur rations et
de votre appel via est bien c'est qu'on
prend nos peuples que c'était à eux
d'agir pour faire fléchir le
gouvernement
alors au-delà aujourd'hui je demande
puisque le peuple doit manifester quelle
est la tâche du sénateur exactement ont
près de du sénat pour le peuple
merci gilberte d'accord alors je peux
peut-être répondre pour le dit le député
ou la députée que je suis nous lorsque
nous sommes à l'assemblée nationale nous
portons les sujets que le peuple
veut qu'on fait un des sujets qui sont
légitimes par exemple quand je prends la
parole la semaine dernière sur le fait
qu'on n'a pas tenu
la ministre n'a pas tenu sa parole sur
l'augmentation du minimum vieillesse et
de la hache pour les personnes âgées et
handicapées c'est parce que sur le
territoire c'était un vrai engagement et
c'était une attente des gilet jaune
donc nous on est dans la fonction de
porter la voix de questionner de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement sur
des sujets vie chère par exemple où je
suis allé voir la présidente de
l'autorité de la concurrence où nous
allons avoir un rendez-vous avec le
cabinet de monsieur le maire pour
activer certains dossiers qui me
tiennent à coeur
donc nous on est là pour porter les
messages des gis les jeunes parce que
nous sommes à l'assemblée nationale et
que nous avons cette fonction est
également de faire des propositions de
loi ou nous battre sur des propositions
de loi avec des amendements pour faire
avancer vos sujets par exemple ce jeudi
de la semaine dernière on a beaucoup
bataillé sur le sujet de la
scolarisation des enfants handicapés qui
est un vrai un vrai problème
ça a été blackboulé par le gouvernement
voilà nous ce qu'on regrette enfin en
tout cas moi ce que je regrette c'est
que on aurait pu organiser la parole des
gels et jaune vers paris sous une
formule soit en visio soit sur une
réunion préparatoire au local ou
peut-être les mers où je sais pas qui
aurait pris la parole pour dire
exactement les cris et le message des
jeunes bref il y aurait pu y avoir une
formule parce que en fait aux antilles a
pas eu de chez les jeunes il y avait qu
à la réunion il y avait eu un mouvement
de gilet jaune donc on aurait pu traiter
ce sujet de façon particulière je le
regrette parce qu'au final bas tous ces
messages la même s'ils ont été exprimés
lorsque la ministre était venu ils ne
l'ont pas exprimé auprès du président de
la république et lui via en juin dit il
mais enjoint le grand débat c'est fini
un merci pour la réponse et pour la
question de jules est vraiment didier en
direct de saint joseph bonjour 10 11 et
bonjour monsieur parce que les gens
demandaient les droits est arrivé pour
une durée de cinq ans est ce que j'ai la
loi de l'état ou mais c'est la loi du
département alors ça dépend ça dépend du
taux d'incapacité de la personne si la
personne a plus de 80% de handicap ou si
elle a entre 60 et 80 79 % de taux de
handicap
les règles sont différentes si elle a
plus de 80% aujourd'hui et ça c'est
depuis 2016
il y a eu un droit à la hache par
exemple qui est valable non plus 5 en
mai
dix ans et depuis quelques mois avec le
nouvel os nouveau gouvernement il est
valable tout le temps et si c'est moins
de 80% entre 50 et 79 % à ce moment là
en fonction de de la reconnaissance de
ne pas pouvoir avoir un travail
là on peut accorder sur une année les
plus importants donc je ne sais pas quel
taux vous avez mais c'est les règles en
fonction du taux au projet la question
de didier par rapport au handicap il y
avait ça faisait partie des joueurs qui
était annoncé la revalorisation pour le
1er janvier
ben en fait
enfin honnêtement dans toutes les
annonces c'est juste des décisions
nationales qui vont être appliqués sur
le plan pauvreté moi je vois encore
noblecourt
la semaine prochaine je te paye je t'ai
pas contente on a eu un exercice de
crise
oui c'est le délégué à la pauvreté
qu'est avec la ministre je lui ai dit
bon ben ok c'est bien mais vous ne
faites que des mesures nationales n'y a
pas de mesures locales donc sur l' âge
ça va être le timing le temps qui était
prévu pour le national sa veux dire
novembre 2019 et après 2020 pour arriver
à 900 euros
d'accord sûr mais rien d'exceptionnel
pour la réunion ça devait être aux
premiers vous discutiez assembler
plusieurs à l'école
leur genre que c'est très difficile
quand on est député d'opposition parce
que dans un hémicycle très largement
dominée par d'être tarie ça sert ça sert
d'abord sur ce dossier là et bien sûr ça
sert d'abord rade à donner de la voix à
ceux qui ne partagent pas les options
politiques de ce gouvernement
donc ça sert à ça et c'est quand même
bien la deuxième chose c'est être
combatifs et faire avancer quelques
sujets je prends quelques exemples sur
la loi de l'inclusion des enfants
handicapés
nous on voulait des mesures qui soient
un peu forte c'est-à-dire les
accompagnants des enfants handicapés les
evs et sachent qu'ils deviennent des
fonctionnaires voilà et parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plutôt des contrats
précaires ils nous ont offert entre
guillemets le fait que ce soit
maintenant des contrats non plus annuel
sur six ans mais deux fois trois ans et
après ils deviennent en cdi
on appris c'est mieux que tous les ans
pendant six ans
mais c'est parce qu'on voulait tôt qu'on
a fait avant c'est un peu le sujet alors
ça sert à ça et ça sert surtout à
contrôler l'action du gouvernement
nous avons michael au téléphone de saint
pierre bonjour yens oui bonjour bonjour
à quelqu'un qui sur les handicapés par
exemple quelqu'un travaille parce que
dans la vie je pense qu'on est fait pour
progresser pour progresser sinon la
personne touche par exemple un gros
salaire et auparavant il s'agit d'un
gros salaire mais il avait attention
handicapés qui cumulait avec mon salaire
est là maintenant si la personne évolué
de sa vie touche à ça l'est par exemple
elle par exemple 2000 euros il a depuis
droit à sa pension d'invalidité
on le constate en salle validité allons
que alors que le problème de santé
il traîne savates l'on s'assied croire
et je pense que c'est si on remplit
adhérents
parce que valent pourtant levé cette
pension ce serait bien de puis tous deux
mille euros que la france font et
cumulus à son salaire et pourquoi alors
levé alors merci le sujet des personnes
handicapées de leur situation est
vraiment enfin très complète il ya
beaucoup de situations mais monsieur
pose de façon générale le fait est
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine en
commission des affaires sociales et puis
en assemblant en séance en mars on va
traiter une proposition de loi proposé
par madame buffet qui est aussi dans
l'opposition dont vous voyez quand on
est dans l'opposition on est aussi
active
larry charge buffet une proposition là
que j'ai cosigné par ce qu'il ya une
autre aberration c'est que quand vous
êtes personnes handicapées et que vous
êtes mariés eh ben pour vous donner
droit à la hache qui est une prestation
qui est lié à votre handicap
on tient compte des ressources de votre
conjoint du marié de votre épouse ou
votre épouse
ce qui est aberrant ça veut dire par
exemple samedi j'ai rencontré un
monsieur nous on rencontre beaucoup des
dames aussi qu'ils m'expliquent que
l'huile à zéro euro
il n'a pas un euro dans sa poche il doit
demander à son épouse de pouvoir s'il
veut acheter je suis pas un morceau de
pain enfin voilà il ya une question de
dignité est donc là on va on va défendre
cette loi pour que ça ne se passe plus
pareil sur ce que dit monsieur tout à
l'heure c'est qu'à un moment donné soit
on dit il y à des prestations qui sont
liées à la situation physique au
handicap reconnu
et puis après il y à sa capacité à
travailler qui est autre chose mais je
pense qu'on doit bien différencier et on
ne doit pas eu être uniquement sur le
niveau de rémunération il faut
reconnaître le handicap et il faut
donner les prestations pour le compenser
une question par sms de roses mais qui
vous demande ce qu'est devenue la maman
sans la quantité de sucre les produits
qui lorsque votre question parce que
d'abord c'est un c'est une loi qui a été
fait sous le ministère de victorin lurel
et qui avaient été portées par madame
christophe vainqueur qui est toujours
député d'ailleurs de guadeloupe et cette
loi aujourd'hui elle est applicable et
nous dit on appliqués et du ton ça veut
dire que vous je n'ai pas de preuve
qu'elle est appliquée et vous allez me
dire septembre les questions tombe
vraiment bien mais c'est la vérité et je
d'ailleurs j'invite les téléspectateurs
allaient sur ma page facebook pour
suivre mon actualité
oui les auditeurs aussi et ça parce que
on a une ppl alors cette fois une
proposition mois cette fois de france
insoumise que sur laquelle j'adhère et
j'ai fait un rapport sur la santé
également et on va intervenir pour
interrogeant interrogé le gouvernement
sur la malbouffe est un des sujets de la
malbouffe qui crée des problèmes de
santé a abaissé diabète etc
c'est le sucre donc on aura l'occasion
encore une fois d'interroger madame
busin pour lui dire quel est l'état
actuel d'application de la loi qui je
vous le rappelle cette loi doit être
appliquée localement par les services de
l'état contrôlé par les services de
l'état pour vérifier que les taux de
sucre dans les produits locaux sont
identiques au taux de sucre produit au
niveau national ça c'est comme les
produits de dégagement on n'y a aucune
raison de nous faire manger les produits
de basse qualité ou trop sucrés on
arrive en toute fin d'émission
il ya qui appelle à rejoindre le gilet
jaune dans un moment de grève
est ce que les partis politiques ce que
le parti socialiste pourrait à son tour
franchir ce pas alors moi je laisserais
filet mené par des pour le parti
socialiste mais je peux répondre d'un
point de vue personnel en tant qu'élu
depuis le départ sur les gilet jaune les
gilet jaune hondier c'est un mouvement
populaire citoyens de dire nous sommes
des citoyens et nous voulons nous
militer et défendre notre cause seuls
ceux que j'entends cela dit il y a des
gilet jaune des personnes qui savent me
contacter qui me contacte avec qui nous
faisons des séances de travail sur le
fond dont ceux qui souhaiteraient que
nous puissions les rejoindre je suis
bien sûr à la disposition du mouvement
parce que je crois que vous lirez pas
manifesté moi je respecte ça franchement
et mais ceux qui travaillent avec moi
aujourd'hui et ils sont nombreux savent
que je suis dans la cause et que je
porte la parole mais maintenant si les
politiques
sont les bienvenus dans le dans la
manifestation je serai là merci beaucoup
et ericka bareigt merci notre invité
aujourd'hui demain c'est le cas de la
presse merci à vous ici merci beaucoup
et puis sonia le retour tout à l'heure
un bien sûr avec musique première et
puis nous aurons aussi également un jour
un artiste avec françoise hardy merci
d'être avec nous dans quelques secondes
13 heures
êtes vous construisez ou rénover votre
logement vous voulez une maison économe
en énergie où il fait bon vivre
les conseillers info énergie vous donne
tous les conseils et vous accompagne
pour améliorer le confort thermique de
votre maison dit au revoir à la chaleur
de l'été et contacter les conseillers
info énergie au 02 62 250 7 257 prix
d'un appel local
les yeux sont animés par la fp l'énergie
réunion est financé par la région
réunion et l'ademe
il est 13h bien c'est d'écouter la
première
[Musique]
wang wei de reconnu comme président
légitime du venezuela par la france
c'est le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian qui
l'annoncent ce matin sur france inter
six pays européens avaient lancé un
ultimatum au président nicholas maduro
et lui demander d'organiser de nouvelles
élections présidentielles le petit matin
projetée par le président vénézuélien
une nouvelle action des gilet jaune en
corse d'après nos confrères de france
bleu
rcfm une vingtaine d'entre eux bloquent
le dépôt pétrolier de marana depuis 3
heures du matin ils veulent dénoncer le
prix élevé des carburants sur l'île
journée mondiale contre le cancer
aujourd'hui cette bonne nouvelle pour
les malades qui perdent leurs cheveux à
cause d'une chimiothérapie
les perruques seront mieux prises en
charge par la sécurité sociale
elles sont aujourd'hui remboursés à
hauteur de 125 euros par an et d'ici à
la mi-avril le remboursement passera 350
euros un nouvel envoi de soldats
américains la frontière mexicaine
annonce du pentagone 3750 militaires
mobilisés pour une durée de trois mois
et les viennent prêter main forte aux
agents des douanes et de la protection
des frontières finissent l'année du
cheval place à celle du cochon de terre
la chine fêtera ce soir le nouvel an
chinois le nouvel an lunaire même c'est
la plus grande fête du pays de l'année 1
413 millions de voyages sont prévus
pendant cette période
la météo avec vers l'est au spécialiste
de l'assainissement individuel et de la
récupération d'eau de pluie
www.valeo.com un côté si vous avez eu du
soleil ce matin et bien ça va changer
pour cet après-midi sera peut-être moins
chaud face et pas sur un de bonnes
averses prévues essentiellement sur la
partie ouest des eaux du port jusqu'au
sud sauvage ces averses pourront finir
leur course sur les côtes sud et
sud-ouest en l'absence de vent et bien
ces averses ont tendance à faire du sur
place mallet bien sûr la prudence près
des ravines ou bassin est donc de mise
le vent d'est reste faible et les brises
domine en journée quand à la mer et bien
elle est belle et peu agitée elle fait
son intéressant toi la météo avec vers
l'est au spécialiste de l'assainissement
individuel et de la récupération d'eau
de pluie
[Musique]